so how does that feel to you that you
have basically the last footage of both
these men's lives I mean how what kind
of responsibility do you feel that
places on you and and did that affect
you during the the filming process I
mean it'sit's well I the responsibility
that I felt through all of the project
was we're handling people's lives you
know even the villains lives these are
the lives and you know even though show
Borella took the money shouldn't have
taken the money he admits to taking the
money minutes at that part was wrong he
may never admit the kids for cash but he
also destroyed his family his entire
family and his friends and all of it and
they have to live with his legacy and
you know it and I think for us we just
wanted to have an honest portrayal of
the stories and we said that we were not
going to take anything anybody says out
of context we had 600 hours of footage
and you can always take and flip when
you're editing you know somebody did
something that sums me a reality shows
that's what it is it's a constant flip
of what people say so we had to make
sure that we we stayed true to all the
stories and and we did and I'm very
proud of that and and literally from the
journalists to the families to the
judges daughters no one has come to us
and said we got it wrong we took
something out of context no that's not
right that's not what I meant now no one
has has said that and I feel really good
about that
you